you get to pick between a guy you're  struggling paycheck to paycheck forever  so it's 50 50. he's not taking you out  to dinner he ain't buying you [ __ ] like  it's like you you know maybe maybe a  small gift maybe some socks at Christmas  but he's faithful he's never cheated  never leave him option two rich guy he  takes care of all of your bills 100 paid  for you get to go on trips whenever you  want you get to go to dinner whenever  you want but here and there he might  [ __ ] another girl he's not a you're the  only one he loves though  number one why I've been in a  relationship I'm still with my boyfriend  now well we've had no men shout out Ben  we've had no money between us but we've  been happy and that's that's all I need  happiness and security